what's the biggest mystery or Gap in
understanding about Evolution
um is it the Cambrian explosion and if
so how do we what's our best
understanding of how to explain
uh what first of all what is it
um in my understanding in a short amount
of time maybe 10 million years 100
million years something like that a huge
number of animals a variety diversity of
animals were created
um anyway there's like five questions in
there yeah is that the biggest mystery
no I don't know about a particularly big
mystery really anymore I mean it's
there are still mysteries about why then
and I've just said sulfate being washed
into the oceans is one it needs oxygen
and oxygen levels Rose around that time
um so probably before that they weren't
High Enough For Animals what we're
seeing with the Cambrian explosion is
the beginning of predators and prey
relationships we're seeing we're seeing
uh modern ecosystems and we're seeing
arms races and we're seeing
um what we're seeing the full creativity
of evolution Unleashed and so I've
talked about the boring billion nothing
happens for for you know one and a half
one billion years one and a half billion
years
um
the Assumption and this is completely
wrong this assumption is is then then
that you know Evolution works really
slowly and that you need billions of
years to affect some small change and
then another billion years to do
something and it's completely wrong
Evolution gets stuck in a stasis and it
stays that way for tens of millions
hundreds of millions of years and
Stephen J Gould used to argue this he
called it punctuated equilibrium but he
was doing it to do with animals and to
do with the the last 500 million years
or so where it's much less obvious than
if you think about the entire planetary
history and then you realize that the
first two billion years was bacteria
only you have the origin of Life two
billion years of just bacteria oxygenic
photosynthesis arising here then you
have a global catastrophe snowball
Earths and great oxidation events and
then another billion years of nothing
happening and then some some period of
upheavals and then another snowball
Earth and then suddenly you see the
Cambrian explosion this is long periods
of stasis where the world is in a stable
State and is not lean is not geared
towards increasing complexity it's just
everything is in balance and only when
you have a catastrophic level of global
level problem like a snowball Earth it
forces everything out of balance and
there's a Tipping Point and you end up
somewhere else now the idea that that
evolution is slow
is wrong it can be incredibly fast and I
mentioned earlier on you can you know in
theory it would take half a million
years to invent an eye for example from
a light sensitive spot it doesn't take
long to convert uh you know one one one
kind of tube into a tube with Nobles on
it into a tube with with arms on it and
then multiple arms and and then at one
end is the head with it starts out as a
swelling is you know it's not difficult
intellectually to understand how these
things can happen
um it boggles the mind that it can
happen so quickly but we're used to
human time scales and what we need to
talk about is generations of things that
live for a year in the ocean
um and and then in a million years is a
million generations and the amount of
change that you can do can affect in
that period of time is it's enormous and
we're dealing with large populations of
things where selection is sensitive to
pretty small changes and can
uh so again as soon as you throw in
the competition of predators and prey
and you're ramping up the the scale of
evolution it's not very surprising that
it happens very quickly when the
environment allows it to happen so I
don't think there's a big mystery
there's lots of details that need to be
filled in I mean the big mystery in in
biology is consciousness
the big mystery in biology is conscious
what intelligence is kind of a mystery
too
um
I mean you said biology not
psychology
because uh from a biology perspective it
seems like intelligence and
Consciousness all are the same like
weird
like all the brain stuff I don't see
it's intelligence is necessarily that
difficult I suppose I mean I see it as a
form of computing and I don't know much
about Computing so I
you don't know much about Consciousness
either so I I mean I suppose oh I see I
see I see I see I see
um that Consciousness you do know a lot
about as a human being no no I mean I I
think I I can understand the wiring of a
brain as a series of in pretty much the
same way as a computer in in theory
um in terms of
um the circuitry of it
the mystery to me is how this system
gives rise to feelings as we were
talking about earlier on yeah I just I
think I think we oversimplify
intelligence I think the dance the magic
of reasoning
is as interesting as the magic of
feeling
we we tend to
think of reasoning as like
very uh running a very simplistic
algorithm I think reasoning is the
interplay between memory whatever the
hell is going on the unconscious mind
all of that
um
I'm not I'm not trying to diminish it in
any way at all like obviously it's
extraordinarily exquisitely complex and
but but I don't see a logical difficulty
with how it works yeah no I I mean I
agree with you but sometimes
um yeah there's a big cloak of mystery
around consciousness
I mean let me compare it with with
classical versus quantum physics the you
know classical physics is logical and
you can understand
the the kind of language we're dealing
with it's it's almost at the human level
we're dealing with stars and things that
we can see and when you get to quantum
mechanics and things
it's practically impossible for the
human mind to compute what is what just
happened there yeah um I mean that is
the same it's like you understand
mathematically the the notes of a
musical composition that's intelligence
yes but why it makes you feel a certain
way
that is much harder to understand yeah
that's that's really
um but it was it was interesting framing
that that's a mystery at this at the
core biology I wonder who solves
consciousness
I tend to think Consciousness will be
solved by the engineer I mean I think
the person who builds it who tries keeps
trying to build the thing
uh versus biology is such a complicated
system
I feel like it's uh I feel like the
building blocks of Consciousness from a
biological perspective
are like
that's like the final creation of a
human being so you have to understand
the whole damn thing you said the
electrical Fields but like
electrical Fields plus plus everything
at the whole shebang
I'm inclined to agree I mean my my
feeling is from my meager knowledge of
the history of science is that the
biggest breakthrough has usually come
through from a field that was not
related to so so if anyone you know is
not going to be a biologist who solves
Consciousness uh just because biologists
are too embedded in in in in in the
nature of of the problem and then
nobody's going to believe you when
you've done it because nobody's going to
be able to prove that this uh this AI is
in fact conscious and and sad in any
case and any more than you can prove
that a dog is conscious and sad
um so it tells you that it is in good
language and you must believe it but I
think most people will accept if faced
with that that
that's what it is all of this uh
probability though of complex life
I in one way I think why it matters is
that
my expectation I suppose is that we we
will be over the next hundred years or
so if we survive it all that AI will
increasingly Dominate and and pretty
much anything that we put out into space
going looking for other
well for the universe for what's out
there will be AI won't be won't be us we
won't be doing that or when we do it'll
be on a much more limited scale I I
suppose the same would apply to any
alien civilization so perhaps rather
than looking for signs of Life out there
we should be looking for AI out there
but then we Face the problem
um that
I don't see how a planet is going to
give rise directly to AI
you can see how a planet can give rise
directly to organic life
and if the principles that govern the
evolution of life on Earth apply to
other planets as well
and I think a lot of them would
then the likelihood of ending up with
human-like civilization capable of
giving rise to AI in the first place
is massively limited once you've done it
once perhaps it takes over the universe
and maybe maybe there's no issue but it
it seems to me that the the two are
necessarily linked that you're not going
to just turn a sterile Planet into an AI
life form without the intermediary of
the Organics first so you have to run
the the four kind of The evolutionary
computation or the Organics to create AI
how does AI bootstrap itself up without
the aid and feel like I'm an intelligent
designer the origin of AI is going to
have to be in the chemistry of a planet